And I'm pleased today to be
speaking with Doctor Laurie Santos,
who's going to share with us her thoughts
on the question of do animals feel and
think like us.
Laurie Santos is an associate professor
of psychology at Yale University and
director of yelling universities,
comparative Cognition Laboratory.
She received both her ba and phd from
Harvard University and her research
explores the evolutionary origins of
human cognition by studying the cognitive
capacities present and nonhuman primates.
Laurie has won numerous awards for her
scientific achievements and for her
teaching and mentorship,
including the Yale University.
Arthur grew memorial prize for Outstanding
Junior Faculty and the Stanton Prize
from the Society for,
for philosophy and psychology.
She was recently voted one
of popular science magazines,
brilliant 10 young minds.
So I now turn to a very special experts
and emotion interview with the treasure
local colleague of mine,
Dr Laurie Santos.
So welcome Lorrie. Thanks for
speaking today. Thanks for having me.
So I thought what I might do is just
start off a little bit by asking you what
first got you interested in this topic
of emotion and how it can apply to non
humans.
Yeah.
So I actually got interested in nonhuman
animals by actually hanging out with
them, um, as a,
as a college student and had
the opportunity to actually
do some research with
monkeys.
And that actually brought me down to a
very nice warm Caribbean island where I
get to hang out with a bunch
of monkeys for the first time.
And I think I can remember the
moment when I first got interested,
not just in their cognition,
but particularly in their emotion when
I was hanging out on a beach that I was
finding really beautiful and it
was warm and there was a breeze.
And I noticed there was a monkey sitting
right beside me who was like looking
out into the water and seem
to be experiencing exactly
the same things I was.
And it just caused me to think like,
what, what does he know about the world?
What does he know about the scene? Is he
enjoying it? Does he find this beautiful?
Um, and it was kind of a fascinating
moment because I realized that, you know,
we now have these cool tools and cognitive
science where we can answer some of
these, these big questions. And so
that was kind of what got me into it.
That's a nice,
I bet anybody who's had an animal or there
I was going to say whether you have a
pet dog or a cat or even a gold fish,
right?
You can't help but wonder what they're
experiencing and if they experienced some
of the same things that
you do. Excellent. So one,
ask you just a little more about some
of the work you've done in this area.
So I mean, you've really
conducted the, you know, someone,
I'll work here looking at the evolutionary
origins of the human mind through the
study of nonhuman primates such as, you
know, monkeys. And here you found that,
you know, monkey seem to be able to
understand what other people are thinking.
And I wonder what implications do you
think this might have for how monkeys
might understand the emotions of other
people as one type of cognitive process?
Yeah. Well, it's still a
bit of a puzzle. I mean,
if you think about how we
process each other's emotions,
sort of how we empathize with others
seem to have different components, right?
So I can empathize with somebody when
they say stub their toe and that just
involves me,
you know,
thinking about what it would feel like
to experience something like that. Um,
if I think about what it would feel like
for somebody to win the lottery or to
find out, you know, that their
parent had died or something sad.
Those things require much
richer cognitive components.
They really require me to understand
something about the other person's belief,
their intentions,
what they know.
And that's what researchers in primate
cognition have really been focused on.
This question of whether or not other
animals can actually think about what
other individuals see and know the answer.
So far,
at least in the monkey species
we work with seems to be, yes,
nonhuman animals can think
about what others see, a know,
however they fall short if
thinking about what others believe.
And this means there's,
there's sort of a big disconnect between
how we think about the minds of others
and how other primates do that.
We don't yet know whether this translates
into how others think about how
primary is,
think about the emotions of others and
how it translates into empathizing.
But I think these are some big
questions in the field right now.
So it sounds like,
although it's an open question,
they may be able to be empathic,
but it may be a different kind of empathy
than human species experience perhaps.
Yeah. Or it might be, it might be that
they have some aspects of empathy but,
but not others. And I think some
of the work we're doing now,
it seems to be suggesting that they might
have a lot of emotional empathy, um,
but maybe not as much cognitive empathy.
So,
so one example of this is a set of work,
trying to look at whether or not other
primates actually contagiously Jaan. Um,
so as you probably heard
about in this series,
the fact that we yawn when other
individuals young is really just another
mechanism showing that we're kind of
engaging with what others are feeling and
it's just kind of an automatic
response to that. Um,
turns out chimpanzees and other primates
also will contagiously beyond if they
see other individuals yawning.
I'm suggesting that they
have some emotional ability
to experience what others
are experiencing.
The question is just kind of how far does
that go and can we come up with great
ways to test it? Well, it sounds like a
lot of the work you're doing right now,
it's going to be answering some of these
important questions in the upcoming
years or we're trying,
another question I wanted to ask you a
bit about is, I mean you've also taken,
you know,
comparative approach to investigating
the origins of prosocial behavior in
monkeys, which is really, really cool.
And your work here suggest that monkeys
are sometimes but not always willing to
donate even their own food to others.
Right.
So could you say just a bit more
about these findings? Yeah. So this,
this set of work is really trying to
tap into whether other species have this
motivation that we do to
kind of help others. Um, you
just, all things being equal,
you want to see others, you
know, feel good or get more
food or have more welfare.
Um,
and so there's a big set of work now in
the field of primate cognition trying to
see whether other primates do this too.
And the simple tasks that we tend to use
is one that works. Something like this.
You bring a primate subject in a lab and
he can pull one of two different tools
to get access to food. The first tool
can actually give food to another guy,
his friend who's in an another enclosure.
Where's the second tool delivers the
second guy. Nothing. So the question is,
what are primates do? Did they want
to be nice to have than the guy?
Do they pull the first well or are they
kind of mean to the guy pulling a second
12?
Um,
what we find in our own species that we
passed here at Yale completion monkeys
is that these capuchin
monkeys are actually nice.
So if you give them this choice,
more often than not,
they'll pull the tool that
gives the other guys' food.
The problem comes when you start messing
around with the setup a little bit.
So now imagine the same sort of
situation except the second one.
You can't actually see the first
monkey you delivering the food.
So in some sense the first monkey
is behaving anonymously for people.
Probably even if you're anonymous,
you'd want the other guy
to get something nice.
What you see in capuchins is
actually just the opposite. In fact,
when the conclusions are anonymous,
they actually are more likely to pull
the mean for all the tool that gives the
other guy nothing.
And so this is just one result,
but it suggests that the way that
other species actually process,
whether they're willing to give food
to others are willing to be altruistic,
might be quite different than
what we do in our own species.
And it's still really early in this work.
But it suggests that there might be
some big differences in our ability to
empathize with other individuals rewards.
So interesting. It makes me wonder,
you know,
what does the say potentially about the
nature of emotions that monkeys might
actually feel towards others?
And I think we know very
little about it in one of the,
the challenges of work with other animals
is that we can measure their behavior,
right? We can measure which
tool they pull say yes.
But it's actually really tricky for us
to measure what they're experiencing.
You know, do they feel bad when they kind
of don't give the other guys some food,
you know,
do they get happy when he gets the food?
These are measures that are really
tricky for us to actually objectify and
actually study in meaningful ways.
So it sounds like these are some of
the additional challenges and exciting
questions, right? That lie
ahead in this field. Yeah,
and I think this is where there's a
nice marriage between work in effect and
processing in humans and in animals.
You know,
the hope is that we can bring
some of those methods, you know,
the same methods that you use in your own
lab to work with the animals to try to
answer some of these big
issues. Right? I mean,
and that's just leveraging
insights from one field to another.
We can learn so much in this field
of an aspect of science that is so
interdisciplinary as you were alluding to.
Yeah.
So I wanted to ask you a little bit
about your recent work, which, you know,
transcends to a different
domain of the animal kingdom,
where you've looked at some
of our closest companions,
dogs and how they might think and feel.
And I know a lot of people have their own
label beliefs about what their dog can
and can't feel and the extent to which
their dog truly empathizes with how
they're feeling. And I wonder what you
think in this domain, um, and your work,
sort of what have been the core
discoveries here, you know,
about the emotional and sort of cognitive
inner lives of dogs. Some of our most,
you know, intimate, you know, animal
friends, we'd say yes. Yeah, I mean, yeah,
I think if I had to pick the,
the three lists,
things we've figured out recently
in dog cognition work, um,
I guess the first would be just how good
dogs are at reading our own behavioral
cues.
Um,
one of the puzzles in primary cognition
for a long time is it even really
closely related primates,
like chimpanzees were just
really bad at reading human cues.
So you set up a simple task where a human
would point to a cup that had food and
you'd expect a chimpanzee subject
to actually pick up on this.
But chimpanzees would just ignore the
pointing and they just didn't seem to
understand what these cues meant.
And what we're learning is that dog seem
naturally adapted to use the cues that
humans provide.
So unlike to Menzies in the first trial,
dogs will pick up on pointing,
they use human gaze.
They seem to be really well attuned to
our cues and they seem to use them and
socially meaningful ways.
So that was sort of surprised.
Number one is that dogs are even better
than primates when it comes to using
these cues. Um, if I had
to pick kind of number two,
the surprising result cognition world,
um,
I think that would be how good dogs are
at understanding human language. Um,
I mean anybody who has a dog knows
that you can teach dogs, so, you know,
sit and fetched and so on.
But it turns out that dogs are actually
better at understanding some of our
words than we even thought.
And this is the lovely work of
Julianne Kaminsky and her colleagues,
particularly looking at some border
collies species where there are certain
individual to seem to
understand lots of human words.
So if you give them information about
pick this specific toy or pick a toy with
a new name, like a blink get, um,
they can understand these
cues specifically as referring
to particular objects.
Um,
and one of the dogs that community and
colleagues study actually is thought to
understand over a
thousand different words.
So it seems like hugs are much better at
understanding not just our social cues,
but also some of our vocal cues
than we thought. Um, I think the,
the third spot,
what we're learning more about dogs
is actually in the emotional domain,
which might be the one
that's most relevant to the
series that you're doing. Um,
and that's that we're learning
that just like primates,
at least when it comes to reading
physical emotions and emotional contagion,
dogs seem to be even more empathic.
And we originally thought, um,
so a recent study suggests that dogs
are actually also good at contagious
yawning. Um, some 70% of dogs tested, uh,
well contagiously yard if
they see another yon. And um,
and so and so that suggests
that just like primates,
even though their physical features are,
we are,
they might be kind of a weirder than
ours are just different than ours.
They might,
dogs might actually be really in tuned
to their owners emotions and their owners
processing. It's still sort
of early stages in at work,
but it's exciting because it,
again,
we're sort of developing some new methods
to get at some of this stuff. I mean,
so those are three really,
really cool insights that you provided.
And it makes me wonder sort of what do
we think at this point or some of the
biggest puzzles still out there? Yeah,
well there's lots of puzzles. I feel like,
I mean,
I think the one that my students in I
are most interested in is this puzzle
about how dogs are using our social cues,
do they learn and some of the same
social ways that humans do. Um,
one of the cool things we're finding in
developmental psychology right now is
all the ways that children's learning
can actually be constrained by what other
teacher is actually tell them.
And we know very little about
teaching and other animals,
but in some ways dogs provide a perfect
window and did this because they're good
at using our queues. There's just this
big question about how did they use them?
You know,
can they use them to learn about artifacts
or to learn how to categorize? Um,
or is it just they're,
they attended these cues but don't learn
in some of the same ways as humans.
And so the biggest puzzle and the kind
of most exciting thing we're doing at our
dog cognition lab now is to
actually look at dog pedagogy,
to see the dogs pick up on the
same pedagogical cues as humans do.
Very cool stuff you have going
on in your lab. Dr. Santos.
So I wanted to ask you then, as you
think about the future of this field,
where do you see it headed?
Kind of what are the next most important
areas that you see moving forward? Yeah,
well particularly thinking about
the study of animal emotions.
I mean my guess is that the most exciting
next step is going to be to find new
techniques for specifically
measuring animals, emotions,
and I, as I said before,
we're very good at
measuring their behavior,
but I figure it doesn't
necessarily correlate with
how individuals are feeling.
And I think that there's some new
psychophysical techniques. Again,
someone like some of the ones you used
in your own lab might be useful in
studying these kinds of questions.
They might give us a unique window into
actually what's going on inside the
animal's head in terms
of their own emotions.
And so I think at the most exciting
thing in the next step or this field,
particularly with studying emotions,
is actually applying some
of these new techniques, um,
and seeing what they can tell us
about the animal mind. Excellent.
So then when you have students, you
know, when we think about the future,
it's often the students that are at the
forefront when they come to you with an
interest in these kinds of questions or
they're thinking about embarking in this
field, um, and they
come to you for advice.
What do you tell them or what
would you tell them? Well,
the first thing would be to get started,
right?
To actually dive in and do
some research yourself. Um,
one of the nice things about working
animal cognition is that, you know,
even a little kids come up with
the same questions. You know,
little kids want to know, what's
my thinking? What does he know?
Does he know what that word?
And so on.
And so my advice would be to jump
in and start doing it. Um, you know,
if you have access to doing work with
primates, that's fantastic. But many,
many research universities
around the country,
we actually have ways that you involved
in work with dog cognition. Um,
and even if you're listening to this
series and you're not near there,
there are cool new tools on the internet
that can allow you to do some of this
stuff. Um, so my colleagues, uh,
Brian Hare at Duke University has
just started his own website called
[inaudible] dot com and
as part of that mission,
you can get involved in citizen science
and help test your own dog or test other
people's dogs, um, to look
at kind of cool questions.
So even if you're far away from
labs that are doing this stuff,
there are ways for you to get involved.
Um,
but that would be my main
advice is like jump in,
try to see what doing empirical science
with the animals is really like and you
know, see if it's for you. Great.
Well thank you so much for speaking with
us today, Lori. I will. Thanks so much.
Thanks for having me as part
of the series. Yeah, thank you.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Laurie Santos
from Yale University.
Thanks again.